bonjour à tous Dans un instant les
sénateurs vont débattre de la
conservation et de la gestion des
scellés judiciaires dans l'hémicycle des
cellés judiciaires qui peuvent être très
précieux pour résoudre une enquête
lorsqu'ils sont bien analysé bien
exploité mais des cellés qui peuvent
être aussi mal exploité parfois perdu
parfois
détruit on en parle avec tout d'abord
Bernard omomet bonjour président de
l'association Christel association qui
défend les famille des victimes
d'agression criminell non élucidé et on
en parle également avec jean-patric
courtois bonjour sénateur UMP de la soné
Loir vous êtes l'auteur de la question
orale qui va être débattue ce matin dans
l'hémicycle et à laquelle Christiane
tobira la garde des saau va répondre
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure tout abord
jean-patric pour toi pour toi pourquoi
attirer l'attention sur la conservation
des cell judiciaires où et comment ces
cell sont-ils conservés actuellement que
c'est une question si vous voulez
extrêmement importante extrêmement
importante dans deux cas de figure
d'abord c'est l'individu qui a été
condamné qui souhaite la révision de son
procès et qui a besoin pour cel d'un
nombre de preuve parce que le progrès
scientifique est tel que peut-être on va
trouver sur les cell les moyens de
prouver son innocence quand il y a une
erreur on s'aperçoit que de temps en
temps il y a des procès en révision qui
vont au bout et puis la deuxième chose
et surtout j'allais dire pour résoudre
des affaires en cours on s'aperçoit et
le président de l'association Christelle
vous le dira mieux que moi qu'à
l'instant où le meurtre a été commis les
progrès scientifiques ne permettait pas
de pouvoir trouver le ou les ou la
coupable et puis les années passant le
progrès scientifique fait que on peut
arriver à retrouver notamment de l'ADN
mais on pourra imaginer demain d'autres
d'autres sources pour permettre la
vérité et cette vérité on la doit on la
doit à qui on la doit d'abord aux
victimes et puis deuxièmement on la doit
à leur famille parce que c'est une
souffrance pour eux pour ceux qui sont
restés sur Terre que de savoir
qu'aujourd'hui vit encore dans des
conditions de de peut-être à côté de
chez eux l'assassin le ou les assassins
de leurs filles ou de ou de leurs
enfants et puis pour les frères et sœurs
pour les familles vous imaginez le
traumatisme que ça doit et puis en fait
enfin aussi pour les victimes
elles-mêmes qui ont été assassinées au
milieu de leur vie alors qu'ell
demandaient souvent rien du tout et qui
le meurtre ne sera jamais expliqué donc
je crois que pour cela il faut conserver
les cell il faut les cons dans de bonnes
condition ça suppose deux choses d'une
part qu'on rallonge le délai de
conservation qu'on arrête ce fameux
délai de 6 mois que vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi et puis qu'on trouve
des bâtiments dans lequels on puisse
stocker les CL parce qu'aujourd'hui ils
sont généralement conservés dans des
tribunaux dans des endroits qui ne sont
pas forcément adaptés et puis en souvent
on estime que tel ou tel par quand
s'agit de voiture des objets un peu
volumineux c'est pas la peine de les
garder or malheureusement dans nos ville
on a toujours des bâtiments industriels
qui sont vacants donc la proposition que
je fais est la suivante de dire prouve
ons peut-être par par la ville
puisqu'elle a le droit de préemption
vous le savez achetons ces bâtiments
faisons qu'un magistrat honoraire ce qui
coûtera moins cher et ce qui paralisera
pas la justice soit responsable de ce
bâtiment et stockons dans ces bâtiments
pendant une délai beaucoup plus
important les gros matériels qui
pourront servir à la découverte de la
vérité puis pour les plus petits
matériels bah ça peut se garder dans les
dans les palais de justice eux même
puisque le volume et le volum est
beaucoup moindre mais je dire j'en
supplirai tout à l'heure la ministre de
faire quelque chose déjà pour respecter
l'arrêt de la courte cassette qui est à
l'heure actuelle applicable et puis en
même temps pour respecter la douleur des
victimes Bernard remomet justement vous
représentez donc les familles de ces de
ces victimes quel rôle jouent ces cell
dans ces affaires est-ce que parfois la
mauvaise conservation de Cellé a selon
vous joué justement un rôle négatif dans
la résolution d'enquête bien sûr disons
que nous avons pu nous rendre compte à
travers les neuf familles de victimes
que nous défendons que nous représentons
qu'il y a eu disons beaucoup de
d'anomalies pour ne pas dire plus
concernant justement cette
cet archivage des des C il faut bien
voir disons que nous dépendons tous
maintenant puisque tous nos dossiers ont
été regroupés au TGI de Chalon Sur saude
nous avons demandé donc à Monsieur
denier qui était l'ancien procureur de
Chalon de nous montrer un petit peu
comment était le la salle d'archivage
des C les pour ne pas dire plus c'est un
véritable cafarnaum disons on y retrouve
de tout tout est P mê et rien n'est
archivé comme il le faut c'est pour ça
qu'effectivement on avait souhaité
depuis disons un certain nombre d'années
maintenant et que soit mis en place une
véritable réglementation concernant les
cell et non pas une réglementation
lacunaire telle que nous la condissons
maintenant puisque sur l'ensemble de nos
Cellé disons concernant nos neuf
familles certains cellés ont été perdus
en cours d'exploitation dans les
laboratoires d'autres cell ont été
détruits alors que les dossiers é en
phase d'instruction d'autres cell ont
été rendu aux familles sans examen
disons par les laboratoires sans dans re
cherche deadn n rien et euh tout ça fait
que on ne pouvait pas disons accepter
que ça continue comme ça et euh si nous
sommes partis disons de ce constat là
pour nos neuf familles disons qui sont
quand même victimes d'assassinat comme
l' si bien rappelé le sénateur courtois
on a besoin disons de pouvoir faire la
vérité et d'essayer de trouver disons
cette forme de justice qui nous manque
jusqu'à présent et on se dit que de
toute manière ce qui est bon pour nous
est applicable sur toute la France
disons pour l'ensemble des tribunaux ça
concne toutes les familles il y a 60
millions de Français on est tous à la
mercie effectivement d'avoir un jour
malheureusement un enfant assassiné et
on souhaite effectivement disons que ns
C puisse être conservé dans d' bon
condition et enfin disons le le dernier
mot moi ce que je vois c'est que chaque
fois que l'on veut essayer de changer de
modifier ou d'améliorer une
réglementation aussi bien disons
euh point injuste qu'elle soit euh cette
réglementation là elle ne coûte pas cher
elle ne coûte pas cher puisque le
sénateur courtois l'a rappelé on a bien
souvent beaucoup de bâtiments on demande
quoi finalement à ce que euh on puisse
disons enregistrer ces cell disons de
manière informatique et non pas tenu sur
des registres manuel forlioté qui bien
souvent sont égarés c'est ce qui s'est
passé pour nous disons sur charallon
surs et euh on nous dit bah oui mais la
loi prévoit que dans certains tribunaux
bah ça se fait au niveau informatique et
dans d'autres ben il faudra continuer
quand même à la main pendant certain ans
alors si vous voulez bon quand on voit
quand même à quel stade on arrive
maintenant quand on voit les progrès qui
sont faits et qu'on on régit disons
d'une manière aussi archaïque les cell
c'est quelque chose si voulez qui nous
dépasse et qui nous manque l'URE
monsieur courtois qu'est-ce qui bloque
la Chancellerie est au courant de toute
la ce problème de conservation des cell
c'est une question de coût c'est une
question d'organisation c'est un peu les
deux je sais pas on on verra ce que va
répondre madame tobira mais je pense que
ça peut être effectivement un coup mais
ce que je voudrais dire pour le coup on
doit pouvoir effectivement avoir
aujourd'hui un un cours relativement
modeste d'abord parce que par les
systèmes informatiques pour tenir
j'allais dire les fichiers des cellés à
jour ça doit pas coûter énormément cher
bien sûr physiquement quand c'est des
gros euh matériels à garder ça peut être
un tracteur ça peut être une voiture et
tout je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on
peut très bien trouver des bâtiment
industriel et les mairies sont tout à
fait capables de préempter et de louer à
l'état un coût symbolique et de faire
garder ces cell judiciairement par un
magistrat en retraite qui qui existe
d'ailleurs pour le tribunal des pensions
je vous rappelle et deuxièmement pour
les Cellé qui sont beaucoup plus petits
en volume ça peut être un cendrier ça
peut être un vert ça peut être une veste
les archives et les caves des tribunaux
suffiront largement donc je vois pas
aujourd'hui très honnêtement ce qui peut
bloquer pour réformer cette disposition
qui à mon avis ne correspond plus au 21e
siècle elle a sûrement correspondu à une
certaine époque mais aujourd'hui plus au
21e siècle et quand on se met à la
douleur des des des familles c'est pas
admissible et puis je vis aussi parler
de la mémoire des victimes et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a aucune raison
objective pour pas améliorer cet état de
FA et oui vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
ça ça correspond d'autant moins au 21e
siècle que les celllé biologiques les
progrès techniques attendus vont
permettre d'exploiter ce type de celllé
on en attend on en attend beaucoup de de
progrès techniqu en la matière bien sûr
regardez l'ADN les progrès de la
recherche de l'ADN moi j'ai une histoire
dramatique sur le territoire de de
l'agglomération maconnaise et bien en 4
ans les progrès scientifique ont pu
trouver l'ADN qu'on ne trouvait pas il y
a 4 ans donc si les objets n'avaient pas
été gardés dans des conditions satisfait
on ne pourrait pas et aujourd'hui il y a
un présumé innocent bien évidemment mais
enfin qui qui est quand même mis en
prison aujourd'hui qui est suspecté du
meurtre de cette jeune fille parce qu'il
y a eu des progrès scientifiques et ils
iront de plus en plus vite donc
l'intérêt c'est de garder effectivement
les cés je répète encore une fois pour
la mémoire des victimes et puis pour le
réconfort des familles Monsieur H juste
pour conclure vous allez être donc dans
l'hémicycle tout à l'heure avec donc
neuf autres personnes représentant
également les familles de victimes et
bien qu'est-ce que vous attendez de de
la réponse de Christi
on attend surtout effectivement un
aménagement de cette non réglementation
ou même si la réglementation elle existe
elle ne s'applique pas ou elle
s'applique très peu ou très mal disons
suivant les
tribunaux quand on a possibilité de
demander la lune et qu'on ne puisse pas
l'avir c'est une chose là maintenant on
peut la demander on peut même laavir
puisque on est monté sur la lune mais je
dirais que on ne demande que des choses
qui sont concrètes qui sont tangibles
qui peuvent se mesurer disons
fiscalement et
financièrement et donc on ne voit pas en
quoi disons madame tobéa pour avoir dis
disons une une appréciation qui aille un
petit peu à l'encontre de de ce que l'on
dit on na pas l'impression de demander
des choses qui sortent de l'ordinaire on
demande simplement disons et pour la
France entière pour toutes les familles
que des progrès soient faits et ces
progrès là thoriquement c'est quelque
chose qui même si c'est un cout disons
par rapport à la vie et à la valeur
disons nos enfants que nous avons perdu
ça ne présente rien merci monessieur on
prend tout de suite donc la direction de
l'hémicycle pour cette question orale et
le débat sur la conservation et la
gestion des cellés judiciaires l'ordre
du jour appelle la discussion de la
question orale avec débat numéro 7 de
monsieur le Président jean-patric
courtois à madame la garde des saau
ministre de la Justice sur la gestion et
la conservation des scellé judiciaires
la parole est à monsieur jean-patric
courtois auteur de la
question comment
bien monsieur le Président Madame le
Gard des saut chers
collègues dans son rapport annuel pour
l'année 2006 la Cour de la Cour de
cassation constater je la cite la non
conservation de plus en plus fréquente
et de plus en plus rapide des pièces sa
conviction après décision définitive en
application des dispositions de
l'article 41-4 du code de procédure
pénale interdisant toute expertise
complémentaire qui aurait pourtant pu
être utile en raison des progrès
scientifiques et de nature à entraver la
recherche de la vérité la Cour de
cassation a réitéré ce constat à
plusieurs reprises les cell jouent donc
en effet un rôle essentiel dans la
détermination de la vérité aussi bien
dans le cadre de la révision d'un procès
que pour permettre d'identifier l'auteur
d'un crime ou d'un délit pourtant la
remarque présitée de la Cour de
cassation n'a jamais été suivi d' fait
une circulaire a bien recommandé en
1999 puis en 2011 d'allonger les délis
de conservation des cell en tant que de
besoin mais les fait montre que ces
dispositions sont restées largement
insuffisantes le sujet n'est pas nouveau
le Parlement n'est pas resté inactif sur
cette question j'ai relevé de fait que
plusieurs questions écrites ont été
posées au gouvernement pour connaître
les solutions appordées à cette question
de la conservation des scellés la
dernière initiative en date est celle de
mon collègue Jean-Pierre Michel dont la
proposition de loi vise à conserver
pendant 30 ans les objets placés sous
main de justice en cas de condamnation
afin de permettre le cas échéant de
mener de nouvelles investigations en cas
de recours en révision je remarque aussi
que notre collègue Catherine taska a
consacré plusieurs développements à la
question des cell dans son rapport pour
avis sur le budget de la justice
judiciaire pour l'année
2014 cette question est en effet
fondamentale il m'a donc semblit
opportun d'ouvrir ce débat parce que la
bonne gestion des cell conditionne en
grande partie la qualité de la justice
elle-même les avancées technologiques
ont en effet permis de faire déceller de
véritables éléments de preuve en premier
je souhaiterais rappeler brièvement les
règles relatives à la conservation de
ces
le code de procédure pénale ne définit
pas juridiquement le C et utilise
indéféremment des expressions
équivalentes tel qu'objet placé sous man
justice ou objet placé sous c le terme
de C donc un raccourci le C n'est pas
l'objet en lui-même mais le procédé
utilisé pour garantir que l'objet pièce
à conviction est bien l'objet qui a été
saisi le placement souscellé a en fait
une double fonction celle d'assurer
l'authenticité
mais aussi l'intégrité de l'objet saisi
cet objet peut présenter le cas échéant
le caractère d'une preuve plus ou moins
essentiel à un double titre en tant que
tel mais désormais surtout en raison des
traces diverses qu'il peut reler ADN S
et cetera le principe est donc que les
objets placés sous cellés doivent être
conservés tant qu'ils sont utiles à la
manifestation de la vérité dans le cadre
d'une enquête en cours le code de
procédure pénale prévoit que des objets
qui ne sont pas uti à la manifestation
de la vérité peuvent être restitué mais
il faut l'accord de l'autorité
judiciaire compétente la question de la
conservation des cell ne se pose pas
réellement à ce stade la question se
pose en revanche quand la procédure
s'achève par un cassement par exemple ou
après une décision définitive dans ce
cas ces objets ne bénéficient plus de
cette protection les règles de
conservation des cell sont alors fixées
par l'article 41-4 du code de procédure
pénale cet article prévoit que 6 mois à
comptter de la décision de classement ou
6 mois après le prononcé de la décision
par la dernière juridiction saisie les
objets deviennent de fait propriété de
l'État après cette présentation rapide
des règles applicables au cell plusieurs
constats peuvent être fait la durée
incompressible de conservation des Cellé
imposé l'état après la fin d'une
procédure est particulièrement faible
puisqu'elle n'est je le rappelle que de
6 mois après cette période l'état étant
devenu propriétaire des objets rien ne
l'empêche en effet d'en disposer
librement il peut les conserver il peut
les vendre mais il peut aussi les
détruire ce qu'il fait d'ailleurs le
plus souvent le choix de conserver ou de
faire détruire les objets dépend donc
des magistrats du parquet pour des
raisons d'organisation la conservation
des scellé pouvant être particulièrement
lourde et très coûteuse des destructions
de scellé sont régulièrement opérées ce
délai de 6 mois résulte d'une
modification introduite par la loi 99
515 du 23 juin 19 99 renforçant
l'efficacité de la procédure pénale en
effet auparavant la durée de
conservation était 3 ans avant que les
Célé ne deviennent propriétés de l'État
l'État était donc tenu de les conserver
au moins pendant cette durée avant de
pouvoir procéder à leur destruction en
1999 la principale raison avancée pour
diminuer de 3 ans à 6 mois la durée
après laquelle l'État devient
propriétaire des objets et peut donc de
ce fait en disposer librement était une
une raison de gestion la conservation
des scelllé était à l'époque jugée très
coûteuse dans ce rapport sur le projet
de loi notre ancien collègue Pierre
Fauchon observé et je les cite le projet
de loi propose de ramener la durée
légale de garde des objets à 6 mois ce
qui paraît être une mesure d'économie
heureuse qui ne devrait pas nuire aux
intérêts des propriétaires la période de
6 mois esttant suffisante lorsqu'un
propriétaire souhaite la restitution de
son bien j'observe qu'à l'époque la
question d'un risque de destruction trop
rapide des scellé n'avait pas été
envisagé cette mesure n'a cependant pas
réduit les coûts et elle n'a pas du tout
résolu le problème de la mauvaise
gestion des scellés qui est resté un
problème récurrent en effet des celllés
sont souvent perdus éparpillés entre
plusieurs tribunaux nécessitant alors
des recherches longues coûteuses parfois
pour les retrouver au-delà du gâchi
d'énergie de temps c'est une source de
très grande incompréhension de colère
aussi pour les familles des victimes
pour lequel il est très difficile
d'admettre que les recherches ne peuvent
pas être relancées ou qu'une procédure
ne peut pas aboutir parce que les cellés
ont disparu ou sont perdus la mauvaise
gestion des Célé ne dépend donc pas à
mon sens de la durée pendant laquelle
l'État est tenu de conserver les objets
mais bien plutôt de l'absence de
véritable choix dans la gestion des
scelllés une politique mieux raisonnée
Visante à déterminer les scellés devant
être conservé permettrait donc
probablement d'améliorer les conditions
de leur propre conservation en effet si
conserver un Cellé est important les
conserver dans de bonnes conditions est
indispensable car des évolutions
techniques pourront permettre à l'avenir
d'exploiter un Cellé les progrès en la
matière ont été importants le plus connu
étant la possibilité d'effectuer des des
analyses d'ADN par exemple mais la
manipulation sans précaution des Cellé
leur conservation sans soins
particuliers Auer les possibilités de
mettre en œuvre de nouvelles techniques
ou fragilise les résultats qui seront
obtenus dans le même ord d'idée en
druisant des celllé dont il est devenu
propriétaire l'État se prive plus
radicalement de la possibilité
d'utiliser des techniques nouvelles qui
permettront demain d'exploiter ces mêmes
celllé aujourd'hui inutilisables
plusieurs exemples récent ont montré que
cette possibilité n'était pas théorique
dans mon propre département madame la
garde desessau l'assoation
chistel dont je tiens ici à saluer le
travail et la constance m'a sensibiliser
sur ce problème particulier des C et m'a
fait état de plusieurs situations que je
trouve particulièrement révoltant les
cell relatifs à une affaire d'homicide
survenu en 1986 ont été détruit en 2001
alors que la proscription n'était pas
encore acquise et que l'affaire n'était
pas encore résolu sans qu'aucune analyse
génétique ne soit intervenue dans
d'autres affaires les cell ont été
pollués ou perdu ou n'ont jamais fait
l'objet d'examen dans une affaire
survenue en
1990 certains cell ont même été renvoyé
par erreur à la famille je souligne que
cette question n'est pas un problème
ancien qui affecterait des cellés
recueillis à propos d'affaires anciennes
j'ai des exemples d'affaires survenu en
1997 en 1999 plus récemment même où les
cellés ont été tous aussi mal conservés
perdus ou n'ont pas fait l'objet
d'analyse retardant les recherches et
faisant parfois même obstacles des
scellés mal conservés perdus par des
laboratoires mais aussi inexploités
alors qu'il pourrait fournir de précieux
indices créant des obstacles parfois
insurmontables et en tout état de cause
ralentissant très fortement les enquêtes
à contrario des cellés conservés depuis
de nombreuses années ont finalement pu
être exploités soit qu'ils éent été
retrouvés soit que les techniques
nouvelles a rendu possible leur analyse
leur exploitation a alors parfois permis
des avancées très substantielles dans
des dossierers parfois très anciens cet
été les meurtres de deux fillettes à VP
dans l'iser qui remonté à 1991 et 1996
ont connu une avancée très significative
grâce à l'exploitation de Cellé prélevé
à l'époque sur les lieux j'ai cité cet
exemple car il est parlant mais de
nombreuses autres affaires ont connu des
avancées essentielles ces avancées n'ont
été toutefois possibles que parce que la
conservation des scellés avait été
effectué dans de bonnes conditions je me
demande si le fait que la plupart des
celllé sont désormais susceptibles de
prélèvement biologique a bien été
intégré par les divers services chargés
de leur conservation plus largement je
me suis interrogé aussi sur les
modalités de conservation des Cellé de
prélèvement biologique leur conservation
nécessite la mise en place de protocoles
coûteux et compliqués ce sont cependant
des éléments essentiels pour permettre
d'élucider des affaires le recueil de
ces type de Célé est-il développé
certains prélèvements biologiques
nécessitent-il des règles de
conservation différente enfin une
meilleure conservation des Cellé
résoudrait un paradoxe que je trouve à
assez frappant les techniques de recueil
despreuves sur les lieux d'une
infraction se sont très fortement
développées elles sont devenues
naturellement très coûteuse aussi mais
le luxe de précaution déployé est
inutile si en aval les Cellé font
l'objet d'une gestion défectueuse en
dernier lieu je souhaite revenir sur
quelques pistes d'amélioration poss
possible car ce sujet est aussi et
surtout un sujet pratique lié aux
contraintes qu'engend de la conservation
des objets il me semble que l'exercice
consistant à dénoncer une situation sans
proposer de solution serait un peu vain
il me semble tout d'abord important de
réfléchir à la possibilité de ne
conserver qu'une partie des célées ceux
qui sont liés directement à la
Commission des infractions les plus
graves ou à des infractions moins graves
mais dont l'élucidation pourrait
permettre des avancées dans une affaire
criminelle par exemple la possibilité
déjà expérimentée en matière de trafic
de drogue consistant aussi à ne
conserver qu'une partie de l'objet saisi
me semble être aussi une piste pouvant
être étudiée cette politique de
conservation et de gestion des Cellé
pourrait être déterminé au niveau
national mais pourquoi ne pas mutualiser
la gestion des cell entre plusieurs
tribunaux à l'échelle par exemple d'un
ressort d'une cours d'appel il me semble
que cela serait pertinent pour les
celllés dont la conservation est
externalisée c'est-à-dire réalisé en
dehors du tribunal comme les véhicules
par exemple je remarque par ailleurs que
les céles nature biologiques font
l'objet d'une conservation dans un lieu
unique le service central de
préservation des prélèvements
biologiques qui est implanté à Pontoise
depuis 2006 et qui est sous la
responsabilité de la gendarmerie
nationale j'observe d'ailleurs que c'est
un cas assez rare de mutualisation des
moyens entre police et gendarmerie
puisque cette dernière assure la gestion
de ces cl également pour le compte de la
police j'observe que la circulaire du 13
décembre 2011 relative à la conservation
des scellés rappelle que le procureur de
la République
peut décider de conserver les C au-delà
de la durée de 6 mois notamment s'il
n'exclut pas la réouverture d'une
nouvelle information avant l'expiration
du délai de prescription au-delà des
nombreuses circulaires qui est été
prises pour assurer une gestion efficace
des cell dont l'expérience a montré que
l'effectivité était très relative il m'a
paraît donc nécessaire d'opérer une
réforme en profondeur du cadre juridique
actuellement applicable c'est-à-dire
l'article 41 alinéa 4 du Code du code de
procédure pénale afin de mieux préciser
les règles de conservation des scellés
après qu'une décision définitive ait été
rendue sans revenir sur la durée de 6
mois à l'issue de laquelle l'État
devient propriétaire des scellés car ce
mécanisme permet de détruire rapidement
les objets ne présent pas d'intérêt il
pourrait être prévu une obligation de
conservation des celllés alignée sur la
durée de prescription applicable en
matière de crime quand les objets placés
sous scellé sont en lien direct avec la
commission d'actes criminel cela permet
permettrait de mettre fin à un décalage
que je trouve assez choquant entre une
durée de prescription de 10 ans et la
possibilité de détruire dans les 6 mois
une décision d'une décision définitive
des éléments pouvant permettre de
relancer l'enquête en contrepartie d'une
conservation plus longue de ces derniers
scellés mais aussi d'une conservation
mieux effectué tous les autres scellés
pourrai faire l'objet d'une destruction
ou d'une aliénation quasi systématique
dès que le transfert de propriété à
l'État serait intervenu je pense enfin
qu'il est illusoire de prétendre
améliorer la situation de la gestion des
scellés sans augmenter les ressources
qui y sont dédiées mais une gestion
amélioré par la sélection plus fine des
scellés devant être conservé et la
destruction ou l'aliénation plus rapide
des autres scellés devrait permettre
sans doute de dégager des marges de
manœuvre non négligeablees susceptible
d'améliorer la gestion globale des
délais conservés je vouserci de votre
attention je vous remercie madame le
ministre d'avoir accepté de répondre à
ma question merci monsieur le président
dans le débat la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Michel pour le groupe
socialiste madame la ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues d'abord je je m'associe
à ce qu'a dit notre collègue jean-patri
toi sa question en effet est totalement
opportune et elle méritait votre
présence madame la ministre je vous
remercie d'avoir bien voulu venir ce
matin pour quelques instants pour
quelques moments au Sénat cette question
fait suite à d'autres initiatives
parlementaires vous l'avez dit mon cher
collègue notamment à des questions
écrites je retiendrai celle du président
varsman le 13 juillet 2010 et plus
récemment une de vos collègues de
sonéloir madame Cécile untermerer en
février
2013 en effet chaque année à peu près
500000 pièces sont placées sous main de
justice de toute nature j'endrai tout à
l'heure et un certain nombre de
scandales répétés il faut bien le dire
ont amené les autorités judiciaires à
s'inquiéter de la façon dont les c
étaient conservés on peut citer
notamment l'arrestation qui a fait grand
bruit en 2009 du gffier du tribunal de
grande instance de sainte qui
arrondissait ses fins de mois en
revendant un certain nombre de CD du
tribunal et plus grave je trouve
quelques mois plus tard la constatation
que des pièces à conviction très
importante avait été subtilisé
n'existait plus euh dans le dossier
concernant l'affaire Boulin et vous
savez que les héritiers de Monsieur
Boulin euh
essaie toujours de faire reconnaître une
vérité ce qu'il croit être une vérité
c'est-à-dire que Monsieur Boulin ne sait
pas si ne se serait pas suicider
évidemment s'il n'y a plus de pièce dans
le dossier il paraît difficile de
revenir sur cette question
alors l'accour de cassation comme vous
l'avez dit a a dénoncé à plusieurs
reprises et a relevé que la noncervation
de plus en plus fréquente et même de
plus en plus rapide des pièces en
conviction après l'adésion définitive
risquit d'entraver la recherche de la
vérité et euh l'inspe générale des
services judiciaires après notamment le
le le scandale les scandales de 2009 euh
à est passé dans une dizaines de
tribunaux je crois et a rendu
un une un rapport absolument confondant
euh dans lequel et est sans appel on
nous dit que les juridictions ne sont
pas en mesure de connaître avec
précision leur stock de Cé ni de faire
des recherches ou ou d'étiter un
inventaire par type ou bien par dossier
50 % des tribunaux se monent dans
l'incapacité de chiffrer les armes qui
détiennent et cetera et cetera on voit
donc non seulement ça peut être une
entrave à la vérité mais encore une
entrave à la sécurité publique
et
donc certes je dirais certes certes
cette question est moins simple qui peut
y paraître au premier abord en effet la
gestion et la conservation des cellés de
nature très différente ça peut aller
d'un mouchoir de poche en papier à de
l'argent liquide à des quantités très
importantes de stupéfiant notamment
d'héroïnes à des gross cylindr et cetera
et cetera C donc le la
conservation qui recouvre de multiples
aspect touche à la détermination des
pièces à conserver à leur enregistrement
à leur stockage à leur restitution
éventuelle à leur aliénation euh à leur
destruction et elle suppose également
que les les conditions de leur
traçabilité de leur contrôle ainsi que
leur sécurisation soit adaptée et existe
par ailleurs la gestion des C doit
répondre à un certain nombre d'objectifs
qui il faut bien le reconnaître sont
souvent contradictoires et dont la
conciliation est une source de
difficulté d'une part celle du contrôle
et de la maîtrise des saisies d'objets
sous l'autorité et sur la seule décision
du parquet ou du juge chargé de
l'enquête celui de la nécessité
d'allonger d'un certain hypothèse les
délaiis de conservation des objets afin
de prendre en compte la possibilité
d'évolution scientifique de technique
susceptible de contribuer à la
manifestation de la vérité celui de la
mise à exécution des peines de
confiscation ainsi que de la protection
du droit de propriété enfin celui de la
conservation des biens surous la
responsabilité du Directeur du GREF on
l' vu pour sainte dans des conditions
optimale de sécurité tout en
garantissant la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques l'indépendance
l'interdépendance de tous ces intérêts
ainsi que le nombre et la diversité des
acteurs qui interviennent dans le
processus de conservation de gestion des
cell complique l'application du droit
positif et la pratique de gestion en la
matière ceci est absolument indéniable
en effet la chaîne de traitement des cé
n'inclut pas uniquement les directeurs
du GREF et les fonctionnaires du service
des cés ils incu également à la gestion
le procureur général ou le procureur de
la République en particulier est pour
autoriser ou contrôler la saisie le
dépôt ou la sortie du bien l'ensemble
des services du parquet de la chaîne
pénale pour assurer l'enregistrement des
différents événements afférant à la vie
des céés au fin de traçabilité et de
suivi bureau d'ordre service de
l'audiencement grèf correctionnelle
service deexécution des peines
l'ensemble des magistrats du siège juge
d'instruction juridiction de jugement
tel que la Cour d'ASS le tribunal pour
enfant le jue des enfants ou encore le
tribunal de police pour statuer sur le
sort des céés
le premier président le président du
grandal de grande instance en tant que
chef d'établissement la gestion des C
par ailleurs nécessite de nombreuses
relations avec des partenaires
institutionnels soit en amont de la
chaîne de traitement tel que les
services d'enquêteurs la caiss des
dépôts soit à aval comme France Domaine
la direction nationale d'intervention
domaniale le ministère de la Défense les
services spécialités de la police de la
gendarmerie et la Direction de la
Sécurité civile toutes ces
raisons expliquent peut-être une
je
dirais
certain aspect assez brouillon au sein
du ministère de la justice concernant
cette question
mais les les les difficultés ont été
dénoncé à plusieurs reprises et
notamment par l'inspection générale des
services judiciaires l'affux croissant
d'abord de dépôt la hausse des frais de
justice l'encombrement des
locaux
journé j'ai le plaisir de vous retrouver
au début de chaque séance pour vous
faire vivre en direct de l'hémicycle les
temps forts des textes qui sont discutés
par les sénateurs et puis je vous donne
également rendez-vous pour une nouvelle
émission à nous le Sénat elle donne la
parole au sénateur nouvelle génération
élue en septembre 2011 on refait la
séance les réactions à chaud